I think what was interesting to me is
just with the split in this country I
think like I frequently get a question
get questions often you know from
Europeans our Americans Americans seem
so prudish and when it comes to secondly
wait wait wait which Americans are you
talking about red state or blue state
you know urban or rural because we have
nothing in common and that holds true
for sex I think well though you know
there are some there are some
conservative religious groups that are
that are very Pro sex I met I
interviewed a guy who he had this
product it was basically vaginal weight
lifting and it was to strengthen the
Kegel muscles and it's this looks like
sort of a two-sided doorknob and you
would insert it and kind of squeeze it
and pull it up and down and I was
interviewing this guy and as it turns
out he's a Christian it's a Christian
company they had this sort of Christian
symbol I thought I said I said to him
wow that's I wasn't expecting and he
said why and I said oh I don't really
associate sexual pleasure with
Christians I'm sorry that which that
sounds really ridiculous but
conservative Christians and he said no
Chris sexuality is a gift that God wants
us to enjoy anything with the guy was so
open he was talking about well men can
Kegel too you know just hang a washcloth
off it and lift lift lift and I'm like
looking at the logo on the screen which
is sort of this flowing water and and it
was just anyway so you have to be
careful when you make these assumptions
about religious conservatives and
sexuality but anyway as a general
statement there is a a real a schism
recision this is split in this country
and it seems to have both both sides of
it have gone further
I mean they've gone further apart you
know what I mean like that there seems
to be more and more opens and openness
and tolerance in the you know the urban
and liberal community and less and less
in and the other side of the fence so
that's that's really just I mean I again
because I was looking at the physiology
I didn't really I don't really focus too
much on cultural issues
the most cutting-edge work you know
there's a really great lab University of
Texas at Austin that's a great lab
there's good stuff being done you know
so much of it now is is testing drugs
and that's going on you know I mean that
that's really where the cutting edge is
that was not that was I wasn't as
interested in that because for my
perspective as a writer and researcher
it's boring it's you know it's somebody
taking a pill and writing a journal
about whether they felt horny on Tuesday
as opposed to Monday or whatever so but
so there's not that either just there's
just very little of it going on outside
of the pharmaceutical area which was sad
to me because you know the stuff that I
would that I was focused on and I was so
interested in was the explorations of
sex just for the sake of figuring it out
and understanding it like there was this
guy Roy Levin who's now retired he's a
UK sexologist and he was doing the stuff
he's the kind of scientists who think
all right so homosexuals like anal sex
the prostate what role does it play what
does the prostate you know I am what's
going on there so he was you know he
wanted to he was retiring so he never
did get around to doing that but that
kind of stuff were you're willing to sit
you'd willing to say you know I'm
curious nobody who studied this let's
just do it that kind of work was those
guys are all retiring or they're they've
died there's just there's so few of them
out there Giles brinly was another one
another British did a lot of that a lot
of that pioneering work and Masters and
Johnson of course and then 1950s that
was extraordinary what they were doing
at the time that they were doing it so
the big the big names are kind of you
know we've entered an era of lots of
people doing a little bit less exciting
work you know